[Music]
[Music]
if you want a pastrami sandwich go to
Casa de me if you want to chat please
come to Heidi thing this my friends is
the story of the real New Yorker
sandwich and the people who keep the
legacy alive
I've been each year for 20 years any
tourists in the world ignore the hot
doggies
but all you New Yorkers know in the chat
pieces 110th and 1st Avenue
inside the bodega best known as Hajis we
meet Salah
my name is Salah al Kobayashi and I'm
the manager of Hajis Dylan grocery for
50 meters we actually invent the chap
cheese your boss so they get to
chotchkie's where you can on it
[Music]
the ingredients is one burger for
example or two burgers you clap it up
good and you put it with some system
that's the secret the season and
whatever you like like [ __ ] tomatoes
onion that's sanders is an Arabic food
what we don't add cheese over there but
when we come here we do cheese only on a
roll is 375 on a hero that's cost like
five dollars
Hajis is located in a part of New York
that's made up of various kinds of
people with a variety of incomes so
keeping chopped cheese at a price point
everyone can afford has been a top
priority in fact the chopped cheese has
only gone up a dollar in the last decade
we are here for all time helping the
community and serving the community
chef cheese is like everything to the
community because it's affordable and
delicious so everybody liked it we sell
about 200 is Jeff Jesus at the gospel
the chopped cheese has spread beyond
Harlem and into bodegas far and wide
attracting loyal New Yorkers everywhere
it appears but in the end it all comes
back to Hajis and Salah the chef cheese
every day but for me sometimes I don't
need to choose
I make it like a chap Hamburg is the
same thing but no cheese I'm trying to
lose weight that's all sour salty
crunchy I think it's safe to say that
everybody loves a good pickle there's a
little shop just outside of Philly that
takes pickles to a whole new level
welcome to LC is the sandwich shop that
uses trickles instead of bread you want
to try one or two or three my name is
Katherine Cohen and I am the head pickle
proprietor at LCS in Haddon Township New
Jersey LLC's was born out of necessity
our mom is a cancer survivor and was
diagnosed with diabetes and that was
something that she was really struggling
with we decided as a family to start
making our mom sandwiches on pickles
rather than on bread we resurrected an
old family recipe that hadn't been used
in probably a decade and we started from
there part of the process of making our
LC signature pickles involve icing down
the Kirby cucumbers adding sea salt
vinegar onions garlic and that's all I
can tell you because my mom will not be
happy if I reveal what the recipe
actually is
[Music]
part of the concept with LCS was to
create a sanctuary for people that have
dietary restrictions diabetes celiac
pedo gluten-free he found that there was
a need for a bread alternative and the
pickle sandwich became very very popular
one of our best-selling sandwiches is
the Elsie's famous Italian which is ham
capital salami provolone lettuce tomato
onion you can even get it topped with
sriracha mayo hots crushed potato chips
to bite into and LCS signature pickle
sandwich
it really is heaven it's crisp it's
crunchy it really is a fantastic
experience yeah unlike anything I've
ever had before our other option is a
cucumber roll up and you can have the
cucumber roll-ups made with any sandwich
topping you'd like
both pickle and cucumber roll-ups are
served with a pair of chopsticks so it's
really a lot of fun to eat we offer
complimentary pickle brine while you're
at the shop you're welcome to as many
pickle G shots as you can handle
[Music]
people take a pickle pilgrimage to come
here they have rerouted flights they
have driven from Toronto Canada who
experienced Elsie's it makes me feel
awesome because at the core I'm really
an old lady
I just really left a few people
you
astronauts have to deal with a lot of
dangers in space deadly debris harmful
cosmic rays and sometimes a corned beef
sandwich in the 1960s at the height of
the space race space food was either
compressed into utilitarian packages or
pureed into a tube NASA did this in part
to reduce the dangers free floating
crumbs could pose like wreaking havoc on
the space capsules instruments during
the Gemini 3 mission astronaut John
Young didn't quite get the memo when he
snuck a contraband corned beef sandwich
into space sure this sandwich could have
caused a life-threatening accident but
hey wouldn't you want to know how a
sandwich tasted in space here's how the
event played out between Young and his
copilot Gus Grissom and NASA and
Congress didn't think so either
Young was reprimanded for his actions
but luckily for him the incident didn't
derail his career he later was part of
the Apollo 16 mission and walked on the
moon but that time he made sure to leave
his packed lunch at home
[Music]
is this a sandwich how about this or
this the answer is well it depends it's
actually surprisingly complicated
jurisdiction scheme that's Neil Fortin
he's a professor of food law he wrote
the book on it literally just what a
sandwich is is actually defined by the
government federally it's the USDA and
the FDA defining something matters
because it changes how it's inspected
and regulated the hotdog is regulated by
USDA but a hotdog on a bun is regulated
by FDA a sandwich doesn't have actually
a strict legal definition it's more of
the common term that can lead to some
heated arguments by sandwich purists
according to the USDA the hotdog is not
a sandwich but the dictionary says it is
and so does the state of New York
marek is pretty inclusive on the
sandwich question hi I'm David Greco
this is Mike's deli in the real Little
Italy of the Bronx our list of
sandwiches is at least 50 sandwiches we
have the Bronx Tale the Michelangelo
Sophie Lorraine the Raging Bull the
Yankee big boy come on I'll make you one
special that's a New York sandwich
according to the state's Department of
Taxation and Finance not only is a hot
dog a sandwich but so is a burrito
that's because a burrito counts as a
wrap which in New York is a sandwich
okay so what about this it looks and
acts like a sandwich it's an ice-cream
sandwiches sandwiches I would say that
ice-cream sandwiches is a fanciful name
rather than an actual use of the word
sandwich in the traditional sense
fanciful name delicious sandwich
the USDA disagrees but what do they know
however a sandwich is defined we know
that there are all kinds of delicious
food wha is it's well simpler and much
more complicated than it looks on the
surface thanks Neil what if I told you
some of the best Indian food in LA is
next to this busy highway at a gas
station inside a convenience store this
guy certainly likes it let's see how
this plate of Indian burritos ended up
near the Dorito aisle at the bomb bay
Frankie company you'll find Hiram and
his staff making Indian food at a gas
station
Hiram care to explain okay the reason
why we chose this particular gas station
is because our families actually in the
gas station give me a sort business we
have this space for you for quite a
while and we thought well what a great
launchpad traditionally what you might
find is unhealthy non fresh fare and
when you're coming across something
that's not only fresh but it's true to
the most raw ingredients so when we
start with that completely off the wall
pairing you're gonna be starting from a
really low point so all you can go is
high and higher and we're trying to just
set the bar really high since they've
opened the Bombay Frankie company has
received both critical and commercial
success definitely our most popular item
is the Frankie in Bombay sometimes it
can be a rolled-up sandwiches sometimes
it can be an enclosed sandwich what we
tried to do is make it ultimately
relatable to the LA market and make it
really similar to a burrito it's one of
the best things you've ever tried people
say never mix business with friends or
family I say don't knock it until you
try it
the key members of the Bombay Frank
it's my sister priyanka our esteemed
chef mr. Komal Jeet Singh and our staff
having someone come in for the first
time who's never tried Indian food and
are completely engulfed by the
experience they truly realized that not
only is it an Indian food coming from a
gas station and being served in the gas
station that they would try it elsewhere
so by preserving traditional ingredients
tradition preparations traditional
recipes were staying true to not only
ourselves but the region of food for
which we serve and we want to make sure
that you're leaving feeling like you got
the true experience
[Music]